hello oh sorry I didn't see that I was
just being fabulous roll the clip some
TTT we'll have to do like how do you go
through this star game
you can't die if you do let's go through
this like a leaf on come on everyone
this guy let's all go together
it's very badly chopping fun I mean can
yeah I'm the star game I forget where it
is all that how do we get this what are
you doing nothing you go down they
follow the red line
oh I'm class you failed me I'm sorry
oh okay hey hey I thought I was gonna
like explode back right oh this one open
this way oh I open it
hey where are you you figured out the
stairs in the main room we're all ahead
phase phase 4 yeah hey okay we're gonna
go through right hey all right let's all
hold hands and go through three Hey look
at my hand thing what hey never saw that
coming
no mix this is terras the new poor
vision you were right Ken well it's kind
of a thing of the portal kills you like
yeah let's all go to it thank you
Hey okay everyone calm the [ __ ] down
calm down calm the [ __ ] down so just
calm down
it's gonna be okay Ken it's gonna be
okay now listen listen up okay here's
the story okay about a little guy that
and all day and all night and everything
he sees is boom but like him inside out
class who his house with wood and
everything is blue poop poop and narrow
and everybody around it's nothing right
what I'm looking for you guys I got
nobody
same to listen to listen to listen uh
I'm gonna have to think you're a traitor
now so I don't think you're following
the rules
that wasn't me we went to beat Charlotte
I don't see drops oh good
when the beat drops you just kill
everyone out of other works out that's
how it works we're gonna sing another
song now okay so what we can say next I
know they say you're killing it when you
do really well but you're not really
supposed to actually you know that
German movie had that musical unban
Hills their health earlier okay that one
what the sound of move you say the B
doesn't really drop in that song there
anyplace just be put there here's a lob
of the [ __ ] up there here's a live [ __ ]
no [ __ ] sound of music by the
[ __ ] up yeah now go on is shuck my dad
even rhyme Oh me damn they knew what
they were doing they know what they were
doing when they wrote that song says
Davis together already and I am my phone
all night long hey guys oh you're gonna
help
how's it going hey Krieger I gotta play
pokemon pokemon okay
you guys like Pokemon I don't you me
Jesus yes it is terrible tears
you sound so convincing hey don't shoot
me
after you shoot I was hoping if I was
calm enough about it you wouldn't
actually shoot me back how they don't
worry she's just amazing I was typing it
when I might have everyone in the room
the cops wouldn't shoot me I'll do it
sir just right for something you're not
so lonely about it hey guys
what's that Oh kilink right that's a
regular Monday no terrorists and am just
Tereus with it okay no more am i
shooting unless you have yeah fate of
roles pity power rules
you're right guys but rules rules I
still don't know who I am it's still
preparing it's stuck on it so I could be
whatever right now so if I shoot you I
could still be innocent no he turned it
on very fast I'm innocent
what the [ __ ] is this by the way I'm
innocent I swear what is this don't
shoot me if I shoot you back because I
am an innocent yes thanks
what are you doing can I trust it ok ok
I trust you I feel bad about I feel very
bad about that
and I want to apologize properly if you
come here and let me Paula Joe
why are you dead
who are you shooting are you shooting I
keep healthy eggs what the [ __ ] you
doing try then then what then we're
better than that
Oh God so we have to cry you're Ken and
Ken did it
yeah crying here super little health why
are you running scared
he's like full house how I be around him
whoa this is okay
it was a 64 like ages ago what'd you get
in here
uh well I shred you were terrible you
get a nice shot oh I know I could have
wanted to do it dramatically oh that was
so much I'll make effects dramatic
smashes kids what's their traditional
Swedish song smoke don't smoke groan and
I ll stay gasps a dobro - Moe Road Anna
Elsa got a box all day yeah it is yeah
yeah Oh Dan wait the beach is about to
drop
cool oh my gosh gaga gaga gaga
you're not even the [ __ ] [ __ ] was it
you god damn it the bleep drop I'm
killing themselves
Jesus clear across the beat drop me beep
does it mean everyone needs to drop as
well he was doing the Frog part hey get
on the front part whoa chase namaka oh
hey hey guys we're yeah we're yet I mean
young but follow the bullets hey how are
you sir come here
you know I don't I asked Shay got some
real cool forget this is the bullets
okay I hear it alright check this out
Goomer come on I swear to god I'm not
gonna do anything bad
hey here you go fight okay yeah all
right yeah yeah I'm gonna can't see the
shock just get in there
I'm tight yeah we're gonna yeah everyone
at every yea-ah
all right ah ah check this out check
this out check it out it's red now whoa
and now it's great whoa why is your
trainer hey what's the drink no the seat
right in front thanks for a minute oh
it's just about to give my story - all
right you have to see far it's Massey
phone now how longs it take this stuff
to go off dude good recommend blue and
yellow is awesome thing
kena how far you another new one I just
ants planets it okay yeah why more to go
dude I'm gonna stop playing it tomorrow
I'm never gonna play it ever well you're
just wrong out of cheek to have you that
bleep Ifans he's a polka hater drop you
miss the Gandalf Bing City gun for huh
uh huh it's the gun down big nothing i
misclicked because I was trying to click
the protection hug see you're staying
there for a long time I mean look not
even that talking about where you go you
going we're talking about pokemons I
think the beats about to drop know
what's happening it's just so good okay
hey Jake wait smoking days as you
thought you and something oh ah [ __ ]
news
yes terrorists ever come on I didn't
know where which bottom we watch you
[ __ ] hey guys that's funny
hey you take it please Oh
that's funny
you [ __ ] saw through that [ __ ] right
away I'm just like dude drop my gun too
that's kind of a dead giveaway out but
well I'm in there I'm gonna stretch it
maybe
hi I'm Abbi I didn't handle it very well
now but I figured it was super bad liar
no no no you want to see a good lie yeah
ken is beautiful you want to see a good
liar ken is ugly
what am I Who am I I think you were
poking me of a pokey which one Snorlax
squirtle X he's my favorites hello come
on in booth [ __ ] shot Hey oh yeah you
could beat us not drop sir the beat is
not yeah you [ __ ] killed my main who
is me see ya my man Mick see ya
put me on body put me put me by a corpse
oh hey together I may add together I
never loved anyone more than than you I
think I poop my pants I got a dog filing
towards the skin to skin oh thanks for
really enjoyed that she's really happy
right now
hey hey oh I'm looking for weapons all
right
the tear you close me in there yes you
you really fell in a [ __ ] no [ __ ] I'm
sorry
help I'm stuck hey Wow
oh sure what
how are you shooting me I said damn it
first I was good believing that it did
though yes you really did
okay well you were so traitor so you
don't feel too bad lucky okay okay I
remember the rules guys I think we're
getting a little sidetracked on what
we're doing
you're the one cheek meat you don't know
me
and I saw you and you enjoyed this one a
little x-rated ya know well live like
anyway I appreciate all the support you
boys give there's one more of this
coming up and it's even better than this
one so if you want it let me know and
I'll see you then my shower my ha ha ha
good outro now look hey pump there's two
gay guys humping in the other Riverhead
you looking at a jerk for the game I get
a little shielding your bet
that's so weak I mean we would never
cover it up guys it's just like that I
don't worry about being gay your hair